The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of
MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu
PROFESSOR: So we started by
talking about thermodynamics.
And then switched off to
talking about probability.
And you may well ask, what's
the connection between these?
And we will eventually try
to build that connection
through statistical physics.
And maybe this lecture
today will sort of
provide you with why these
elements of probability
are important and essential
to making this bridge.
So last time, I started with
talking about the Central Limit
Theorem which pertains to
adding lots of variables
together to form a sum.
And the control parameter
that we will use
is this number of
terms in the sum.
So in principle,
there's a joint PDF
that determines how these
variables are distributed.
And using that, we can calculate
various characteristics
of this sum.
If I were to raise the
sum to some power m,
I could do that by doing a sum
over i running from let's say
i1 running from 1 to N, i2
running from-- im running
from 1 to N, so basically
speaking this sum.
And then I have x of
i1, x of i2, x of im.
So basically I multiplied m
copies of the original sum
together.
And if I were to calculate
some moment of this,
basically the moment of a sum
is the sum of the moments.
I could do this.
Now the last thing
that we did last time
was to look at some
characteristic function
for the sum related to the
of this joint
probability distribution,
and conclude that actually
exactly the same relation holds
if I were to put index
c for a cumulant.
And that is basically, say the
mean is the sum of the means,
the variance is sum of
all possible variances
and covariances.
And this holds to all orders.
OK?
Fine.
So where do we go from here?
We are going to gradually
simplify the problem in order
to get some final
result that we want.
But that result eventually
is a little bit more general
than the simplification.
The first simplification
that we do
is to look at
independent variables.
And what happened when we
had the independent variables
was that the
probability distribution
could be written as the product
of probability distributions
pertaining to different ones.
I would have a p1 acting
on x1, a p2 acting on x2,
a pn acting on the xn.
Now, when we did that,
we saw that actually one
of the conditions that would
then follow from this if we
were to Fourier transform and
then try to expand in powers
of k, is we would never get in
the expansion of the log terms
that were coupling
different k's.
Essentially all of the joint
cumulants involving things
other than one variable
by itself would vanish.
So essentially in that
limit, the only terms
in this that would
survive we're the ones
in which all of the
indices were the same.
So basically in that
case, I would write this
as a sum i running from one
to N, xi to the power of N.
So basically for
independent variables,
let's say, the variance is
the sum of the variances,
the third cumulant is the sum of
the third cumulants, et cetera.
One more simplification.
Again not necessary
for the final thing
that we want to have in mind.
But let's just assume
that all of these
are identically distributed.
By that I mean that this is
basically the same probability
that I would use for
each one of them.
So this I could write
as a product over i one
to N, the same p for each xi.
Just to make sure you sum
notation that you may see every
now and then, variables that
are independent and identically
distributed are
sometimes called IID's.
And if I focus my attention
to these IID's, then
all of these things are
clearly the same thing.
And the answer would be
simply N times the cumulant
that I would have
for one of them.
This-- actually some
version of this,
we already saw for the
binomial distribution
in which the same
coin, let's say,
was thrown N independent times.
And all of the cumulants for
the sum of the number of heads,
let's say, were related to
the cumulants in one trial
that you would get.
OK?
So fine.
Nothing so far here.
However let's imagine now that
I construct a variable that I
will call y, which
is the variable
x, this sum that I have.
From it I subtract
N times the mean,
and then I divide
by square root of N.
I can certainly choose to do so.
Then what we observe here
is that the average of y
by this construction is 0.
Because essentially, I make
sure that the average of x
is subtracted.
No problem.
Average of y squared--
not average of y squared,
but the variance.
Surely it's easy to show
the variance doesn't really
depend on the subtraction.
It is the same thing
as the variance of x.
So it is going to
be essentially x
squared c divided
by square of this.
So I will have N.
And x squared, big x
squared cumulant,
according to this rule,
is N times small x
squared cumulant.
And I get something like this.
Still nothing interesting.
But now let's look
at the m-th cumulant.
So let's look at y m c for
m that is greater than 2.
And then what do I get?
I will get to N times x m c
divided by N to the m over 2.
The N to the power
of m over 2 just
came from raising this
to the power of m,
since I'm looking at y to the m.
And x to the m c, according
to this, is N times x1.
Now we see that
this is something
that is proportional to the N to
the power of 1 minus m over 2.
And since I chose m
to be greater than 2,
in the limit that N becomes
much, much larger than 1,
this goes to 0.
So if I look at the limit where
the number of terms in the sum
is much larger than
1, what I conclude
is that the probability
distribution for this variable
that I have constructed has
0 mean, a finite variance,
and all the other
higher order cumulants
are asymptotically vanishing.
So I know that the
probability of y,
which is this variable that
I have given you up there,
is given by the one distribution
that we know is completely
characterized by its first
and second cumulant, which
is the Gaussian.
So it is exponential of minus y
squared, two times its variance
divided, appropriately
normalized.
Essentially this sum is
Gaussian distributed.
And this result
is true for things
that are not IID's so long
as this sum i1 to im, one
to N, xi1 to xim goes as
N goes to infinity, much,
much less than 1,
as long as it is
less than-- less than strictly
than N to the m over 2.
So basically, what
I want to do is
to ensure that when I
construct the analog of this,
I would have something that when
I divide by N to the m over 2,
I will asymptotically go to 0.
So in the case of IID's,
the numerator goes like N,
it could be that I
have correlations
among the variables et
cetera, so that there
are other terms in the sum
because of the correlations
as long as the sum total
of them asymptotically
grows less than N
to the m over 2,
this statement that
the sum is Gaussian
distributed it is
going to be valid.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Question--
how can you compare
a value of [INAUDIBLE] with
number of variables that you
[INAUDIBLE]?
Because this is
a-- just, if, say,
your random value is
set [? in advance-- ?]
PROFESSOR: So basically,
you choose a probability
distribution-- at least in
this case, it is obvious.
In this case, basically
what we want to know
is that there is a
probability distribution
for individual variables.
And I repeat it
many, many times.
So it is like the coin.
So for the coin I
will ensure that I
will throw it hundreds of times.
Now suppose that for
some reason, if I throw
the coin once, the
next five times
it is much more likely to be the
same thing that I had before.
Kind of some strange
coin, or whatever.
Then there is some
correlation up to five.
So when I'm calculating
things up to five,
there all kinds of
results over here.
But as long as that's five
is independent of the length
of the sequence, if I throw
things 1,000 times, still only
groups of five that
are correlated,
then this result still holds.
Because I have the additional
parameter N to play with.
So I want to have a
parameter N to play with
to go to infinity which
is independent of what
characterizes the
distribution of my variable.
AUDIENCE: I was mainly
concerned with the fact
that you compare
the cumulant which
has the same dimension
as your random variable.
So if my random variable is--
I measure length or something.
I do it many, many times
length is measured in meters,
and you try to compare it
to a number of measurements.
So, shouldn't there be
some dimensionful constant
on the right?
PROFESSOR: So
here, this quantity
has dimensions of
meter to m-th power,
this quantity has dimensions
of meter to the m-th power.
This quantity is dimensionless.
Right?
So what I want is
the N dependence
to be such that when I go
to large N, it goes to 0.
It is true that this
is still multiplying
something that has-- so it is.
AUDIENCE: It's like less than
something of order of N to m/2?
OK.
PROFESSOR: Oh this
is what you-- order.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: The last time
[INAUDIBLE] cumulant
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes, thank you.
Any other correction,
clarification?
OK.
So again but we will
see that essentially
in statistical
physics, we will have,
always, to deal with
some analog of this N,
like the part number of
molecules of gas in this room,
et cetera, that enables us
to use something like this.
I mean, it is clear
that in this case,
I chose to subtract the mean
and divide by N to the 1/2.
But suppose I didn't have
the division by N to the 1/2.
Then what happens is that I
could have divided for example
by N. Then my
distribution for something
that has a well-defined,
independent mean
would have gone to something
like a delta function
in the limit of N
going to infinity.
But I kind of sort
of change my scale
by dividing by N to
the 1/2 rather than
N to sort of emphasize that
the scale of fluctuations
is of the order of
square root of N.
This is again something
that generically happens.
So let's say, we know the
energy of the gas in this room
to be proportional to
volume or whatever.
The amount of
uncertainty that we have
will be of the order of
square root of volume.
So it's clear that we
are kind of building
results that have to do with
dependencies on N. So let's
sort of look at some other
things that happen when we are
dealing with large number
of degrees of freedom.
So already we've
spoken about things
that intensive, variables such
as temperature, pressure, et
cetera.
And their characteristic
is that if we express them
in terms of, say, the
number of constituents,
they are independent
of that number.
As opposed to extensive
quantities, such as the energy
or the volume, et cetera,
that are proportional to this.
We can certainly
imagine things that
would increase [INAUDIBLE]
the polynomial, order of N
to some power.
If I have N molecules
of gas, and I
ask how many pairs of
interactions I have,
you would say it's N, N
minus 1 over 2, for example.
That would be
something like this.
But most importantly, when we
deal with statistical physics,
we will encounter
quantities that
have exponential dependence.
That is, they will
be something like e
to the N with some something
that will appear after.
An example of that is when we
were, for example, calculating
the phase space
of gas particles.
A gas particle by itself can
be in a volume V. Two of them,
jointly, can occupy
a volume V squared.
Three of them, V
cubed, et cetera.
Eventually you hit V to
the N for N particles.
So that's a kind of
exponential dependence.
So this is e g V
to the N that you
would have for joined
volume of N particles.
OK?
So some curious
things happen when
you have these
kinds of variables.
And one thing that
you may not realize
is what happens when you
summing exponentials.
So let's imagine that
I have a sum composed
of a number of terms i running
from one to script N-- script n
is the number of terms
in the sum-- that
are of these exponential types.
So let's actually sometimes I
will call this-- never mind.
So let's call these
e to the N phi--
Let me write it in this fashion.
Epsilon i where epsilon i
satisfies two conditions.
One of them, it is positive.
And the other is
that it has this kind
of exponential dependence.
It is order of e to
the N phi i where
there could be some prefactor or
something else in front to give
you dimension and stuff like
that that you were discussing.
I assume that the
number of terms
is less than or of the
order of some polynomial.
OK?
Then my claim is
that, in some sense,
the sum S is the largest term.
OK?
So let's sort of put
this graphically.
What I'm telling you is that
we have a whole bunch of terms
that are these epsilons i's.
They're all positive, so I
can sort of indicate them
by bars of different lengths
that are positive and so forth.
So let's say this is epsilon
1, epsilon 2 all the way
to epsilon N. And let's say
that this guy is the largest.
And my task is to add up the
length of all of these things.
So how do I claim that the
length is just the largest one.
It's in the following sense.
You would agree that
this sum you say
is certainly larger
than the largest term,
because I have added
lots of other things
to the largest term, and
they are all positive.
I say, fine, what
I'm going to do
is I'm going to raise the
length of everybody else
to be the same thing
as epsilon max.
And then I would say
that the sum is certainly
less than this artificial sum
where I have raised everybody
to epsilon max.
OK?
So then what I will do is I will
take log off this expression,
and it will be bounded by log
of epsilon max and log of N
epsilon max, which is the same
thing as log of epsilon max
plus log of N. And
then I divide by N.
And then note that the
conditions that I have set up
are such that in the limit
that N goes to infinity,
script N would be
P log N over N.
And the limit of this as N
becomes much less than 1 is 0.
Log N over N goes to 0
as N goes to infinity.
So basically this sum
is bounded on both sides
by the same thing.
So what we've established
is that essentially log of S
over N, its limit as
N goes to infinity,
is the same thing as a
log of epsilon max over N,
which is what?
If I say my epsilon max's have
this exponential dependence,
is phi max.
And actually this is again
the reason for something
that you probably have seen.
That using statistical
physics let's
say a micro-canonical
ensemble when
you say exactly
what the energy is.
Or you look at the
canonical ensemble
where the energy can
be all over the place,
why do you get the same result?
This is why.
Any questions on this?
Everybody's happy, obviously.
Good.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
a question?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: The N on
the end, [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: There's a script N,
which is the number of terms.
And there's the Roman N,
which is the parameter that
is the analog of the number
of degrees of freedom.
The one that we usually
deal in statistical physics
would be, say, the
number of particles.
AUDIENCE: So number of
measurements [INAUDIBLE] number
of particles.
PROFESSOR: Number
of measurements?
AUDIENCE: So the
script N is what?
PROFESSOR: The script N
could be, for example, I'm
summing over all
pairs of interactions.
So the number of pairs
would go like N squared.
Now in reality
practicality in all cases
that you will deal with,
this P would be one.
So the number of terms
that we would be dealing
would be of the order of the
number of degrees of freedom.
So, we will see some
examples of that later on.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
script N might be N squared?
PROFESSOR: If I'm forced
to come up with a situation
where script N is
N squared, I would
say count the number of pairs.
Number of pairs if
I have N [? sides ?]
is N, N minus 1 over 2.
So this is something that
goes like N squared over 2.
Can I come up with
a physical situation
where I'm summing over
the number of terms?
Not obviously, but it could
be something like that.
The situations in statistical
physics that we come up with
is typically, let's say, in
going from the micro-canonical
to the canonical
ensemble, you would
be summing over energy levels.
And typically, let's
say, in a system
that is bounded the
number of energy levels
is proportional to the
number of particles.
Now there cases that actually,
in going from micro-canonical
to canonical, like the energy
of the gas in this room,
the energy axis goes all
the way from 0 to infinity.
So there is a continuous version
of the summation procedure
that we have that is
then usually applied
which is in mathematics
is called the saddle point
integration.
So basically there, rather
than having to deal with a sum,
I deal with an integral.
The integration is over
some variable, let's say x.
Could be energy, whatever.
And then I have a quantity that
has this exponential character.
And then again, in
some specific sense,
I can just look at the largest
value and replace this with e
to the N phi evaluated at x max.
I should really write
this as a proportionality,
but we'll see what
that means shortly.
So basically it's
the above picture,
I have a continuous variable.
And this continuous
variable, let's
say I have to sum a quantity
that is e to the N phi.
So maybe I will have to
not sum, but integrate over
a function such as this.
And let's say this is the
place where the maximums occur.
So the procedure
of saddle point is
to expand phi
around its maximum.
And then I can write i as an
integral over x, exponential
of N, phi evaluated
at the maximum.
Now if I'm doing
a Taylor series,
then next term in
the Taylor series
typically would involve
the first derivative.
But around the maximum,
the first derivative is 0.
Again if it is a maximum,
the second derivative phi
double prime evaluated at
this xm, would be negative.
And that's why I indicate
it in this fashion.
To sort of emphasize that it
is a negative thing, x minus xm
squared.
And then I would have higher
order terms, N minus xm cubed,
et cetera.
Actually what I will do is I
will expand all of those things
separately.
So I have e to the minus
N over 6 phi triple prime.
N plus N over 6 phi triple
prime, evaluated at xm,
x minus xm cubed, and then the
fourth order term and so forth.
So basically there is
a series such as this
that I would have to look at.
So the first term you can
take outside the integral.
And the integration
against the one of this
is simply a Gaussian.
So what I would
get is square root
of 2 pi divided by the variance,
which is N phi double prime.
So that's the first term
I have taken care of.
Now the next term
actually the way
that I have it, since I'm
expanding something that
is third order around a
potential that is symmetric.
That would give me 0.
The next order term, which is
x minus xm to the fourth power,
you already know how
to calculate averages
of various powers with the
Gaussian using Wick's Theorem.
And it would be
related to essentially
to the square of the variance.
The square of the variance
would be essentially the square
of this quantity out here.
So I will get a correction
that is order of 1 over N.
So if you have
sufficient energy,
you can actually numerically
calculate what this is
and the higher order
terms, et cetera.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Could
you, briefly remind
what the second term
in the bracket means?
PROFESSOR: This?
This?
AUDIENCE: The whole thing,
on the second bracket.
PROFESSOR: In the numerator,
I would have N phi m, N phi
prime.
Let's call the deviation y y.
But phi prime is 0
around the maximum.
So the next order
term will be phi
double prime y squared over 2.
The next order term will be phi
triple prime y cubed over 6.
e to the minus N phi triple
prime y cubed over 6,
I can expand as 1 minus N phi
triple prime y cubed over 6,
which is what this is.
And then you can go and do that
with all of the other terms.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Isn't it
then you can also
expand as N the local maximum?
PROFESSOR: Excellent.
Good.
So you are saying, why didn't
I expand around this maximum,
around this maximum.
So let's do that.
xm prime xm double prime.
So I would have a series
around the other maxima.
So the next one would be N to
the phi of xm prime, root 2
pi N phi double
prime at xm prime.
And then one plus order of 1
over N And then the next one,
and so forth.
Now we are interested in the
limit where N goes to infinity.
Or N is much, much
larger than 1.
In the limit where N
is much larger than 1,
Let's imagine that
these two phi's
if I were to plot not e
to the phi but phi itself.
Let's imagine that
these two phi's are
different by I don't know,
0.1, 10 to the minus 4.
It doesn't matter.
I'm multiplying
two things with N,
and then I'm comparing
two exponentials.
So if this maximum was at 1,
I would have here e to the N.
If this one was at
1 minus epsilon,
over here I would have e
to the N minus N epsilon.
And so I can always ignore
this compared to that.
And so basically, this
is the leading term.
And if I were to take its log
and divide by N, what do I get?
I will get phi of xm.
And then I would get
from this something
like minus 1/2 log of N phi
double prime xm over 2 pi.
And I divided by N,
so this is 1 over N.
And the next term would be
order of 1 over N squared.
So systematically,
in the large N limit,
there is a series
for the quantity log
i divided by N that
starts with phi of xm.
And then subsequent terms
to it, you can calculate.
Actually I was kind
of hesitant in writing
this as asymptotically
equal because you
may have worried
about the dimensions.
There should be something
that has dimensions of x here.
Now when I take the log it
doesn't matter that much.
But the dimension
appears over here.
It's really the size of the
interval that contributes which
is of the order of N to the 1/2.
And that's where
the log N comes.
Questions?
Now let me do one example of
this because we will need it.
We can easily show
that N factorial
you can write as 0 to infinity
dx x to N, e to the minus x.
And if you don't
believe this, you
can start with the integral
0 to infinity of dx
e to the minus alpha
x being one over alpha
and taking many derivatives.
If you take N
derivatives on this side,
you would have 0 to N dx x to
the N, e to the minus alpha x,
because every time, you
bring down a factor of x.
On the other side, if you
take derivatives, 1 over alpha
becomes 1 over
alpha squared, then
goes to 2 over alpha cubed, then
go c over alpha to the fourth.
So basically we will N
factorial alpha to the N plus 1.
So I just set alpha equals to 1.
Now if you look at the thing
that I have to integrate,
it is something that
has a function of x,
the quantity that I should
integrate starts as x to the N,
and then decays exponentially.
So over here, I have
x to the N. Out here I
have e to the minus x.
It is not quite of the
form that I had before.
Part of it is proportional to
N in the exponent, part of it
is not.
But you can still use
exactly the saddle point
approach for even this function.
And so that's what we will do.
I will write this as
integral 0 to infinity dx e
to some function of x where
this function of x is N
log x minus x.
And then I will follow that
procedure despite this is not
being quite entirely
proportional to N.
I will find its maximum
by setting phi prime to 0.
phi prime is N over x minus 1.
So clearly, phi prime
to 0 will give me
that x max is N. So the
location of this maximum
that I have is in fact N.
And the second derivative,
phi double prime,
is minus N over x squared, which
if I evaluate at the maximum,
is going to be minus 1 over
N. Because the maximum occurs
at the N.
So if I'm were to make a
saddle point expansion of this,
I would say that N factorial
is integral 0 to infinity, dx
e to the phi evaluated at x
max, which is N log N minus N.
First derivative is 0.
The second derivative
will give me minus 1
over N with a factor
of 2 because I'm
expanding second order.
And then I have x
minus this location
of the maximum squared.
And there would be higher order
terms from the higher order
derivatives.
So I can clearly take e to
the N log N minus N out front.
And then the
integration that I have
is just a standard Gaussian
with a variance that
is just proportional to N.
So I would get a root 2 pi N.
And then I would have
higher order corrections
that if you are energetic,
you can actually calculate.
It's not that difficult.
So you get this Stirling's
Formula that limit of large N,
let's do log of N factorial is N
log N minus N. And if you want,
you can go one step further,
and you have 1/2 log of 2 pi N.
And the next order term
would be order of 1/N.
Any questions?
OK?
Where do I need to use this?
Next part, we are going to talk
about entropy, information,
and estimation.
So the first four
topics of the course
thermodynamics, probability,
this kinetic theory of gases,
and basic of
statistical physics.
In each one of them, you will
define some version of entropy.
We already saw the
thermodynamic one
as dQ divided by T meaning dS.
Now just thinking
about probability
will also enable you to
define some form of entropy.
So let's see how we go about it.
So also information,
what does that mean?
It goes back to
work off Shannon.
And the idea is as
follows, suppose
you want to send a
message of N characters.
The characters
themselves are taken
from some kind of
alphabet, if you
like, x1 through xM
that has M characters.
So, for example
if you're sending
a message in English
language, you
would be using the
letters A through Z.
So you have M off 26.
Maybe if you want
to include space,
punctuation, it would
be larger than that.
But let's say if you're
dealing with English language,
the probabilities of
the different characters
are not the same.
So S and P, you are going to
encounter much more frequently
than, say, Z or X. So let's say
that the frequencies with which
we expect these characters
to occur are things like P1
through PM.
OK?
Now how many possible
messages are there?
So number of possible
messages that's are composed
of N occurrences of alphabet
of M letters you would say
is M to the N. Now, Shannon was
sort of concerned with sending
the information
about this message,
let's say, over a line
where you have converted it
to, say, a binary code.
And then you would say
that the number of bits
that would correspond to M to
the N is the N log base 2 of M.
That is, if you really
had the simpler case
where your selections was just
head or tail, it was binary.
And you wanted to
send to somebody
else the outcome of
500 throws of a coin.
It would be a sequence of
500 0's and 1's corresponding
to head or tails.
So you would have to send
for the binary case, one
bit per outcome.
If it is something
like a base of DNA
and there are four things,
you would have two per base.
So that would be log 4 base 2.
And for English, it would
be log 26 or whatever
the appropriate number is
with punctuation-- maybe
comes to 32-- possible
characters than five
per [? element ?].
OK.
But you know that
if you sort of were
to look at all possible
messages, most of them
would be junk.
And in particular, if you had
used this simple substitution
code, for example, to
mix up your message,
you replaced A by
something else, et cetera,
the frequencies
would be preserved.
So sort of clearly a nice way to
decode this substitution code,
if you have a long
enough text, you sort of
look at how many
repetitions they are
and match them with
their frequencies
that you expect for
a real language.
So the number of
possible messages--
So in a typical
message, what you
expect Ni, which is Pi
N occurrences, of xi.
So if you know for example, what
the frequencies of the letters
in the alphabet are, in
a long enough message,
you expect that typically
you would get that number.
Of course, what
that really means
is that you're going
to get correction
because not all
messages are the same.
But the deviation
that you would get
from getting something that is
proportional to the probability
through the frequency in the
limit of a very long message
would be of the order
of N to the 1/2.
So ignoring this
N to the 1/2, you
would say that the typical
message that I expect
to receive will have characters
according to these proportions.
So if I asked the
following question,
not what are the number
of all possible messages,
but what is the number
of typical messages?
I will call that g.
The number of typical
messages would
be always of distributing
these number of characters
in a message of length N. Again
there are clearly correlations.
But for the time
being, forgetting all
of the correlations, if
[? we ?] [? do ?] correlations,
we only reduce this number.
So this number is much,
much less time M to the N.
Now here is I'm going to make an
excursion to so far everything
was clear.
Now I'm going to say something
that is kind of theoretically
correct, but
practically not so much.
You could, for
example, have some way
of labeling all possible
typical messages.
So you would have-- this would
be typical message number
one, number two, all the way
to typical message number g.
This is the number
of typical message.
Suppose I could point out to
one of these messages and say,
this is the message
that was actually sent.
How many bits of
information would I
have to that indicate
one number out of g?
The number of bits
of information
for a typical message, rather
than being this object,
would simply be log g.
So let's see what this log g is.
And for the time being,
let's forget the basis.
I can always change
basis by dividing
by log of whatever quantity
I'm looking at the basis.
This is they log of N factorial
divided by these product over i
of Ni factorials which
are these Pi N's.
And in the limit of
large N, what I can use
is the Stirling's Formula
that we had over there.
So what I have is N log N
minus N in the numerator.
Minus sum over i Ni
log of Ni minus Ni.
Of course the sum over
Ni's cancels this N,
so I don't need to
worry about that.
And I can rearrange this.
I can write this as
this N as sum over i Ni.
Put the terms that are
proportional to Ni together.
You can see that
I get Ni log of Ni
over N, which
would be log of Pi.
And I can actually then
take out a factor of N,
and write it as sum
over i Pi log of Pi.
And just as a excursion,
this is something
that you've already
seen hopefully.
This is also called
mixing entropy.
And we will see
it later on, also.
That is, if I had
initially a bunch of,
let's say, things that
were of color red,
and separately in a
box a bunch of things
that are color green, and
then bunch of things that
are a different color,
and I knew initially
where they were in
each separate box,
and I then mix them up
together so that they're
putting all possible
random ways,
and I don't know
which is where, I
have done something
that is irreversible.
It is very easy to take
these boxes of marbles
of different colors
and mix them up.
You have to do more work
to separate them out.
And so this increase
in entropy is
given by precisely
the same formula here.
And it's called
the mixing entropy.
So what we can see
now that we sort of
rather than thinking
of these as particles,
we were thinking of
these as letters.
And then we mixed up the
letters in all possible ways
to make our messages.
But quite generally for
any discrete probability,
so a probability that has a
set of possible outcomes Pi,
we can define an
entropy S associated
with these set of probabilities,
which is given by this formula.
Minus sum over i Pi log of Pi.
If you like, it is also this--
not quite, doesn't makes
sense-- but it's some kind
of an average of log P.
So anytime we see a
discrete probability,
we can certainly do that.
It turns out that also we will
encounter in cases later on,
where rather than having
a discrete probability,
we have a probability
density function.
And we would be very tempted
to define an entropy associated
with a PDF to be something
like minus an integral dx
P of x log of P of x.
But this is kind of undefined.
Because probability density
depends on some quantity
x that has units.
If this was probability
along a line,
and I changed my units
from meters to centimeters,
then this log will
gain a factor that
will be associated with
the change in scale
So this is kind of undefined.
One of the miracles
of statistical physics
is that we will find
the exact measure
to make this probability
in the continuum
unique and independent of
the choice of-- I mean,
there is a very
precise choice of units
for measuring things that
would make this well-defined.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: But that would be
undefined up to some sort of
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: After
you [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: So you can still
extract dependencies from it.
PROFESSOR: You can
still calculate things
like differences, et cetera.
But there is a certain
lack of definition.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the
relation between this entropy
defined here with the
entropy defined earlier,
you notice the parallel.
PROFESSOR: We find
that all you have to do
is to multiply by
a Boltzmann factor,
and they would become identical.
So we will see that.
It turns out that the heat
definition of entropy,
once you look at
the right variables
to define probability with, then
the entropy of a probability
distribution is
exactly the entropy
that comes from the
heat calculation.
So up to here, there is a
measured numerical constant
that we have to define.
All right.
But what does this have to
do with this Shannon story?
Going back to the story, if I
didn't know the probabilities,
if I didn't know
this, I would say
that I need to pass on
this amount of information.
But if I somehow constructed
the right scheme,
and the person that
I'm sending the message
knows the probabilities,
then I need
to send this amount of
information, which is actually
less than N log M.
So clearly having knowledge
of the probabilities
gives you some ability,
some amount of information,
so that you have
to send less bits.
OK.
So the reduction in number
of bits due to knowledge of P
is the difference between N log
M, which I had to do before,
and what I have to
do now, which is
N Pi sum over i Pi log of Pi.
So which is N log M plus
sum over i Pi log of Pi.
I can evaluate
this in any basis.
If I wanted to really count in
terms of the number of bits,
I would do both of these
things in log base 2.
It is clearly something that
is proportional to the length
of the message.
That is, if I want to send a
book that these twice as big,
the amount of bits will
be reduced proportionately
by this amount.
So you can define
a quantity that
is basically the
information per bit.
And this is given the
knowledge of the probabilities,
you really have gained
an information per bit
which is the difference of log
M and sum over i Pi log Pi.
Up to a sign and this
additional factor of log N,
the entropy-- because I can
actually get rid of this N--
the entropy and the information
are really the same thing
up to a sign.
And just to sort of
make sure that we
understand the
appropriate limits.
If I have something
like the case
where I have a
uniform distribution.
Let's say that I say that
all characters in my message
are equally likely to occur.
If it's a coin, it's unbiased
coin, it's as likely in a throw
to be head or tail.
You would say that if
it's an unbiased coin,
I really should send one
bit per throw of the coin.
And indeed, that will
follow from this.
Because in this
case, you can see
that the information
contained is
going to be log M. And then
I have plus 1 over M log of 1
over M. And there are M
such terms that are uniform.
And this gives me 0.
There is no information here.
If I ask what's the
entropy in this case.
The entropy is M terms.
Each one of them have
a factor of 1 over M.
And then I have a
log of 1 over M.
And there is a minus
sign here overall.
So this is log of M.
So you've probably seen this
version of the entropy before.
That if you have M
equal possibilities,
the entropy is
related to log M. This
is the case where all of
outcomes are equally likely.
So basically this is
a uniform probability.
Everything is equally likely.
You have no information.
You have this maximal
possible entropy.
The other extreme
of it would be where
you have a definite result.
You have a coin that
always gives you heads.
And if the other
person knows that,
you don't need to
send any information.
No matter thousand times,
it will be thousand heads.
So here, Pi is a delta function.
Let's say i equals to five
or whatever number is.
So one of the
variables in the list
carries all the probability.
All the others
carry 0 probability.
How much information
do I have here?
I have log M. Now when I
go and looked at the list,
in the list, either P is 0, or
P is one, but the log of 1 and M
is 0.
So this is basically
going to give me 0.
Entropy in this case is 0.
The information is maximum.
You don't need to
pass any information.
So anything else is in between.
So you sort of think
of a probability that
is some big thing, some
small things, et cetera,
you can figure out
what its entropy is
and what is
information content is.
So actually I don't
know the answer.
But presume it's very
easy to figure out
what's the information
per character
of the text in English language.
Once you know the
frequencies of the characters
you can go and calculate this.
Questions.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Just to
clarify the terminology,
so the information
means the [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: The number
of bits that you
have to transmit to
the other person.
So the other person
knows the probability.
Given that they know
the probabilities,
how many fewer
bits of information
should I send to them?
So their knowledge
corresponds to a gain
in number of bits, which
is given by this formula.
If you know that the
coin that I'm throwing
is biased so that it
always comes heads,
then I don't have to
send you any information.
So per every time
I throw the coin,
you have one bit of information.
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: The equation, the
top equation, so natural
log [INAUDIBLE] natural
log of 2, [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: I initially
calculated my standing formula
as log of N factorial
is N log N minus N.
So since I had done
everything in natural log,
I maintained that.
And then I used this
symbol that log, say, 5 2
is the same thing that maybe
are used with this notation.
I don't know.
So if I don't indicate a number
here, it's the natural log.
It's base e.
If I put a number so log,
let's say, base 2 of 5
is log 5 divided by log 2.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Log 2, log 2.
Information.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
PROFESSOR: Or if you like, I
could have divided by log 2
here.
AUDIENCE: But so
there [INAUDIBLE]
all of the other
places, and you just
[? write ?] all
this [INAUDIBLE].
All right, thank
you, [? Michael. ?]
PROFESSOR: Right.
Yeah.
So this is the general
way to transfer
between log, natural
log, and any log.
In the language of
electrical engineering,
where Shannon worked, it is
common to express everything
in terms of the number of bits.
So whenever I'm
expressing things
in terms of the number
of bits, I really
should use the log of 2.
So I really, if I want
to use information,
I really should use log of 2.
Whereas in statistical
physics, we usually
use the natural log
in expressing entropy.
AUDIENCE: Oh, so it doesn't
really matter [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It's just
an overall coefficient.
As I said that
eventually, if I want
to calculate to the heat
version of the entropy,
I have to multiply by
yet another number, which
is the Boltzmann constant.
So really the
conceptual part is more
important than the
overall numerical factor.
OK?
I had the third item in my list
here, which we can finish with,
which is estimation.
So frequently you are
faced with the task
of assigning probabilities.
So there's a situation.
You know that there's
a number of outcomes.
And you want to
assign probabilities
for these outcomes.
And the procedure
that we will use
is summarized by the
following sentence
that I have to then define.
The most unbiased--
let's actually
just say it's the
definition if you like--
the unbiased assignment
of probabilities
maximizes the entropy
subject to constraints.
Known constraints.
What do I mean by that?
So suppose I had told you
that we are throwing a dice.
Or let's say a coin, but
let's go back to the dice.
And the dice has possibilities
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
And this is the only
thing that I know.
So if somebody says
that I'm throwing a dice
and you don't know
anything else,
there's no reason for you to
privilege 6 with respect to 4,
or 3 with respect to 5.
So as far as I know, at this
moment in time, all of these
are equally likely.
So I will assign each one of
them for probability of 1/6.
But we also saw over
here what was happening.
The uniform
probability was the one
that had the largest entropy.
If I were to change
the probability
so that something goes up
and something goes down,
then I calculate that formula.
And I find that the--
sorry-- the uniform
one has the largest entropy.
This has less entropy
compared to the uniform one.
So what we have done in
assigning uniform probability
is really to maximize the
entropy subject to the fact
that I don't know anything
except that the probabilities
should add up to 1.
But now suppose
that somebody threw
the dice many, many times.
And each time they
were throwing the dice,
they were calculating
the number.
But they didn't give us
the number and frequency
is what they told us was that
at the end of many, many run,
the average number that
we were coming up was 3.2,
4.7, whatever.
So we know the average of M.
So I know now some
other constraint.
I've added to the
information that I had.
So if I want to reassign
the probabilities given
that somebody told me that
in a large number of runs,
the average value of
the faces that showed up
was some particular value.
What do I do?
I say, well, I maximize S which
depends on these Pi's, which
is minus sum over i Pi
log of Pi, subjected
to constraints that I know.
Now one constraint
you already used
previously is that the
sum of the probabilities
is equal to 1.
This I introduce here through
a Lagrange multiplier,
alpha, which I will adjust later
to make sure that this holds.
And in general, what we do if
we have multiple constraints is
we can add more and more
Lagrange multipliers.
And the average of M is
sum over, let's say, i Pi.
So 1 times P of
1, 2 times P of 2,
et cetera, will give you
whatever the average value is.
So these are the two constraints
that I specified for you here.
There could've been other
constraints, et cetera.
So then, if you have a
function with constraint
that you have to extremize, you
add these Lagrange multipliers.
Then you do dS by dPi.
Why did I do this? dS by
dPi, which is minus log of Pi
from here.
Derivative of log P is 1 over P,
with this will give me minus 1.
There is a minus alpha here.
And then there's a minus
beta times i from here.
And extremizing means I
have to set this to 0.
So you can see that the
solution to this is Pi--
or actually log of Pi,
let's say, is minus 1
plus alpha minus beta i.
So that Pi is e to
the minus 1 plus alpha
e to the minus beta times i.
I haven't completed the story.
I really have to
solve the equations
in terms of alpha and
beta that would give me
the final results in terms
of the expectation value of i
as well as some
other quantities.
But this is the procedure
that you would normally
use to give you the unbiased
assignment of probability.
Now this actually goes back to
what I said at the beginning.
That there's two ways of
assigning probabilities,
either objectively by actually
doing lots of measurement,
or subjectivity.
So this is really
formalizing what
this objective procedure means.
So you put in all
of the information
that you have, the number
of states, any constraints.
And then you maximize
entropy that we
defined what it
was to get the best
maximal entropy for the
assignment of probabilities
consistent with
things that you know.
You probably recognize this form
as kind of a Boltzmann weight
that comes up again and
again in statistical physics.
And that is again natural,
because there are constraints,
such as the average
value of energy,
average value of the
number of particles,
et cetera, that consistent
with maximizing their entropy,
give you forms such as this.
So you can see that
a lot of concepts
that we will later on be
using in statistical physics
are already embedded in these
discussions of probability.
And we've also seen how the
large N aspect comes about,
et cetera.
So we now have the
probabilistic tools.
And from next
time, we will go on
to define the
degrees of freedom.
What are the units that we
are going to be talking about?
And how to assign them some
kind of a probabilistic picture.
And then build on into
statistical mechanics.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So here,
you write the letter i
to represent, in this case, the
results of a random die roll,
that you can replace it with any
function of a random variable.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So I could have, maybe
rather than giving me
the average value of the number
that was appearing on the face,
they would have given
me the average inverse.
And then I would have had this.
I could have had
multiple things.
So maybe somebody else
measures something else.
And then my general
form would be
e to the minus beta
measurement of type one,
minus beta 2 measurement
of type two, et cetera.
And the rest of thing over
here is clearly just a constant
of proportionality
that I would need
to adjust for the normalization.
OK?
So that's it for today.